[Music]
with his Harebrained Schemes and asinine
dealings with the gods king midas ruled
the ancient kingdom of Phrygia with an
uneven hand he was known in greek
mythology as a rogue ruler whose antics
been mused his people and distracted the
gods midas spent his days in a stupor of
splendor spoiling himself and his
beloved daughter and gorging himself on
feasts and wine unsurprisingly he felt
an affinity with Dionysus god of wine
Carnival and performance
one day midas discovered a satyr dozing
in his rose garden and drunk on more
than the scent of flowers midas
recognized the satyr as one of dionysus
followers and let him nurse his hangover
at the palace pleased with the Kings
hospitality Dionysus offered to grant
him one wish midas cast a greedy eye
over his surroundings despite the luxury
in which he lived no amount of precious
jewels finest silk or splendid decor
felt like enough his life he thought was
lacking luster what he needed was more
gold the God sent the power to turn
anything became touched to gold surging
through - ecstatic he turned to his
possessions at his lightest touch the
palace walls transformed stone statues
shown
and goblets glittered
he galloped through his home in a frenzy
handling each item until it took on a
lustrous sheen soon the palace heaved
with gold and Midas's delirious laughter
echoed off the walls exhausted and
hungry from his rampage midas picked up
a bunch of grapes from his newly gilded
fruit bowl but he nearly shattered his
teeth for the fruit had turned to metal
in his mouth when he picked up a loaf of
bread the crumbs hardened in his hand
flinging himself onto his bed in
frustration Midas discovered his plush
pillows had morphed into solid gold
hearing his cries of frustration his
daughter entered the room but when Midas
reached out to her he saw with horror
that he had frozen her into a golden
statue horrified at what he had done
mitos begged the gods to rid him of his
power taking pity on the foolish King
Dionysus told Midas to wash his hands in
the river pact Alice when Midas reached
into the river the gold drained from his
fingertips midas returned home to find
his daughter alive and his palace back
to normal and he rejoiced you'd think he
would have learned his lesson but just a
few weeks later midas blundered again
insulting the music and Sun god Apollo
when he declared pan a greater musician
Apollo scornfully declared that the king
must have the ears of an ass to make
such a misjudgment and transformed Midas
accordingly
once again regretting his behavior might
escaped his hairy ears hidden in public
they were seen only by his barber who
was sworn to secrecy during a very
awkward grooming session the barber
stifled his laughter and fought the
desire to tell someone
yet the secret consumed him one day he
walked outside the city and dug a hole
in the ground plunging his head into the
earth
the desperate barber whispered Midas has
ass's ears
soon after a clump of reeds sprang up in
the spot where the barber had buried his
words when the wind blew they carried
the echoes of his whisper through the
breeze Midas has ass's ears at the sound
donkeys in the fields raised their heads
in recognition and people chuckled to
themselves at the follies of their king
with his golden touch and asses ears
- was not the most respected ruler and
where other leaders were honoured
through statues and temples his people
remembered him a little differently in
the depths of the glittering River and
the rustle of the Phrygian wind we
really enjoy telling these myths and are
on a mission to share stories from all
over the world help us out and leave
your favorite myth in the comments and
check out this playlist for more myths
[Music]